l'événement scientifique de cette
semaine à venir le départ dans l'espace
de john glen à 77 ans le plus vieil
astronautes du monde devrait partir à
bord de la navette discovery jeudi
prochain une opération scientifique mais
surtout très médiatique c'est du moins
ce qu'affirme aux états unis les
détracteurs de cette mission patrice
pollet et claude sicard il n'y a pas
photo ce vol là est bien le plus
médiatique depuis 20 ans car parmi les
sept membres d'équipage s'est glissée
invités hors norme
john glenn 77 ans la présence du
vénérable astronautes fait la différence
avec d'autres missions tombé dans les
oubliettes de l'histoire
car avec glen comme au bon vieux temps
de la conquête spatiale
c'est le succès garanti pendant neuf
jours les yeux du monde entier vont
scruter glen en apesanteur
l'astronaute le plus rusé de la nasa
on dit que vous êtes un sacré mal un jeu
sous n'étiez pas glen pas sénateur la
nasa vous aurez laissé tomber
que répondez vous nous sommes tous de
vionnaz des voix s'élèvent pour dire que
sa présence à bord ne va servir à rien
de son côté la nasa se défendent de
vouloir faire un joli coup de pub
d'ailleurs glenn a bien un réel travail
à faire mon objectif est de découvrir ce
qui fait fonctionner ou arrêtent le
corps on va s'intéresser au système
immunitaire à la façon dont se défendent
les muscles au phénomène liées à
l'ostéoporose est comme ça j'espère que
la nasa pourra étudier convenablement le
phénomène de vieillissement
imperturbable contre vents et marées
glenn poursuit son entraînement
bien décidé à voler pour la deuxième
fois opiniâtre et fondeur il sait que sa
quête de l'espace et soutenu par
l'opinion publique et la majorité des
astronautes
objectivement il a vraiment une quantité
d'expérience à faire et franchement qui
d'autre que lui est le mieux placé pour
l'image qui représente du premier
américain dans l'espace
le peuple est entièrement derrière lui
pour le revoir vivre cette aventure de
l'exploration version l'an 2000 du vol
spatial marque de faveur exceptionnelle
bill clinton s'est même déplacé pour
voir le héros nationaux leur point
commun ils comptent bien aller tous les
deux jusqu'au bout de leur mission